It is time for Drew's News,
your daily skip down the good news lane.
And with me at the desk is the best copilot in the biz,
Rossi, Ross Matthews.
Yes, high everybody, hi.
(audience clapping)
I get so excited
about the stories we get to tell every day.
I love researching them. I love reading them.
I love unveiling them. It's news you can use.
It is, but can I just get an award first
for best skirt of the day?
Drew Barrymore, your skirt is so cute.
(audience clapping)
Right?
Well I'm feeling you in the front row,
we clearly went for an ombre effect today.
Yes, it's an ombre kind of day and I approve.
You look good.
Well, you've got the first story, so.
All right, you ready for some stories?
I got a good one for you.
(audience clapping)
First up.
Always.
Always, you know it's always a joy
to see the people we love totally fan out
about other things.
Like when you see a celebrity
loving other celebrities and movies.
Well, I love this "Variety" reports
Lady Gaga just got to reveal to Jake Gyllenhaal
that she's obsessed with his movie, "Donnie Darko"
and that's of course, the 2001 indie hit
that turned into a gigantic cult classic.
By the way, it was produced
by none other than Drew Barrymore and Flower Films.
(audience clapping)
And it inspired Lady Gaga.
She said when she was a kid she watched it over and over
and it inspired her fashion, inspired her art.
I mean that's, look at you, you inspiring Gaga.
(audience clapping)
Like I love Lady Gaga so much, everything she does.
When she came out as the man at the MTV awards, I was like,
all right, we're done, there's nothing you can't do.
She's like our generation's David Bowie, I love her.
I love her too.
Well next, for those of you who love
"The Great British Bake Off" anybody watch that show?
(audience clapping)
Well, I mean it's the best.
If you've ever watched it and wondered,
"Hmm, I wonder if they'll ever make a musical out of this?"
Well, you're not the only one, 'cause guess what?
"Food and Wine" reports,
"The Great British Bake Off" the musical
is debuting this summer in England.
They're actually doing it.
Yeah, a musical about the show with 18 original songs,
it'll revolve around eight amateur bakers
and fans will find out who will triumph as a star baker
and who will fall foul as a soggy bottom.
But turning it into a musical
probably gonna be expensive, it costs a lot of dough.
Oh, there it goes.
So stupid, so dumb.
But it got me thinking like,
are there other shows that you love
that they should spin off into musicals?
I don't know.
I would see "The Handmaid's Tale" on Broadway.
Oh, you're so dark.
That is the most depressing musical of all time.
I need it to be dramatico, you know what I mean?
I need ups and downs and love stories.
Like I want "90210" the musical.
(Drew laughing)
They would call it 9021
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
or something stupid, that's pretty good.
I love that.
And you know that's gonna be a musical next.
Next.
(upbeat music)